wir reden viel über die spd die spd hat
wie alle gemerkt haben putin problem ich
sage nur die spd und antworte ich glaube
auch die cdu und zwar in gestalt ihrer
kanzler königin angela merkel die
kanzlerin die für putin nützlicher war
über die vielen jahre hinweg als der
viel gescholtene gerhard schröder sie
hat nämlich
zunächst mal ihr die ukraine
um
geschädigt dadurch dass sie bei der bau
der beim bau der nord-stream-pipeline 2
zunächst mal die europäischen
widerstände bei seite geräumt hat und im
sommer vergangenen jahres auch noch die
amerikanischen sanktionspläne
zerschlagen hat damit war klar wenn
nicht der krieg gekommen wäre die
pipeline wird zu ende gebaut deutschland
oder europa werden noch abhängiger
gewesen von russischem gas punkt 1.2
der
frühere polnische eu ratspräsident
donald tusk hat das als ihren größten
fehler bezeichnet die förderung der
pipeline ich finde es gibt noch vielen
größeren fehler 2008 beim nato gipfel in
bukarest hat angela merkel dafür gesorgt
dass die ukraine nicht in das bündnis
aufgenommen wird george bush der
amerikanische präsident wollte das
damals unbedingt und angela merkel hat
eisern dagegen gestanden hat es
verhindert in ihrem schlepptau der
französische präsident sarkozy man
stelle sich vor die ukraine wäre 2008
aufgenommen worden es hätte die invasion
russlands auf der krim nicht gegeben es
hätte auch die
sagen das unterwandern der ost ukraine
durch russische truppen in den
vergangenen jahren nicht gegeben ganz zu
schweigen vom jetzigen krieg dann
russland hätte sich immer mit der nato
angelegt also das hat verheerende
wirkungen gehabt und ich frage mich wann
eigentlich frau merkel mal dazu stellung
nehmen will zu ihrer eigenen position
sie ist
abgetaucht sie ist aber keine
privatpersonen geworden sie hat ein büro
mit neun angestellten mehr als jeder
andere kanzler vor ihr also ein
arbeitsfähige behörde klein behörde
sozusagen die auch meine rede
aufschreiben kann oder ein interview
organisieren kann und sie selbst und
zwar diese neuen leute bezahlt vom
steuerzahler und sie selbst trägt 15.000
euro pension ungefähr im monat das ist
eine gewisse verpflichtung sie steht
nach wie vor im öffentlichen leben ich
erwarte von angela merkel mal eine
erklärung und einen akt der selbstkritik
also ich würde mir tatsächlich auch
wünschen dass wir mal etwas von angela
merkel zu der gesamten geschichte hören
man muss aber glaube ich schon
feststellen es gibt schon einmal ein
unterschied zwischen gerhard schröder
und angela merkel gerhard schröder ist
auf der payroll von putin lobby irrt
wirklich in einer fast unverschämten art
und weise in den vergangenen jahren für
dieses thema ist ja jetzt dann über
istanbul nach moskau geflogen und wollte
das nicht mal informieren habe ich
einmal
eine frage die mir ganz klar wer hat uns
denn das bessere deutschland
hinterlassen weil sie haben gerade
gerhard schröder angesprochen also dem
sollten wie er den vorwurf machen wann
stand deutschland dann besser da nach
der kanzlerschaft von gerhard schröder
oder nach angela merkel naja also wenn
ich mir beispielsweise die
arbeitslosenzahlen wenn ich mir die
wirtschaftszahlen anschaue dann ganz
klar jetzt und nicht eben vor 16 jahren
als gerhard schröder dann sozusagen
abgegeben hat aber am schluss ist
sozusagen als zehn jahren diese das ist
ihrer unwürdig
sind weiterhin die arbeit einmal jeder
bei ist doch der wahnsinn er kann man
sie ja in ehren halten für die jahre die
sie regiert hat aber das sieht natürlich
profitiert hat von der agenda 2010 dass
die arbeitsmarktmaßnahmen
arbeitsmarktmaßnahmen nicht sofort
gewirkt haben das ist doch jedem klar
das sind ökonomen klar sie als
finanzfachmann auch als gymnasiallehrer
wissen das genauso und insofern aber die
frage was auf die freundlich höflich
transport haben eine wand stand
deutschland basiert auf der seite nach
wir haben die hinterräder nachrede
märkte unter der marke lancia schäden
nicht über die bilanz von schröder und
merkel der rede über die frage wer
barceló er geholfen hat und wer für ihn
nützlicher war gerhard schröder war nach
dem ende seiner kanzlerschaft 2005 nicht
mehr als ein aushängeschild der
russischen energiekonzerne er saß bei
der gazprom bei den pipeline
tochtergesellschaften und bei rosneft in
den aufsichtsorganen aber er hatte ja
keine keine politischen
eingriffsmöglichkeiten er war nicht mehr
kanzler während angela merkel kanzlerin
war und mit ihrer mit ihren politischen
fähigkeiten in die weltpolitik
eingegriffen hat um putin zu helfen
einmal in der hinsicht dass sie die die
nord stream 2 durchgesetzt hat wie sie
wegen des ukraine kriegs gestopft werden
musste und zweitens weil sie die
aufnahme der ukraine die nato verhindert
hat das waren einschneidende
entscheidungen solche einschneidenden
entscheidungen zugunsten von putin hat
schröder nie getroffen konnte er gar
nicht er war aus dem geschäft stimmt
aber der ukrainische botschafter namik
hat mir mal 2009/10 schon gesagt hat
sich nach dem bundestag gearbeitet habe
er hat so angst dass sie geht denn in
dem jahr an dass in dem sie ihr amt
verlässt wird er angreifen und genau das
ist passiert dass ich dem nicht
zustimmen wie gesagt auch mal ein
argument dagegen was man beim nato
gipfel in bukarest
2008 wo und was habe ich jetzt nicht
okay
deine these ist ja ganz klar dass frau
merkel die ukraine also dass sie in die
un aufgenommen werden müssen 2008 in die
nato in die nato aufgenommen werden
erhalten werden müssen sowie sehen denn
jahr 2008 er weiß noch gar nicht im
deutschen bundestag und will mir also im
nachhinein ist natürlich jeder jetzt
schlauer ein punkt hätte ich
es wäre doch jetzt ist wäre doch jetzt
wohl viel zu sagen ja also man hat das
alles schon immer gewusst und 2008 hätte
man dann zu einer anderen entscheidung
kommen müssen im nachhinein stimmt das
natürlich das ist was sie gerade eben
ausgeführt haben eine argumentation ist
natürlich aus meiner sicht auch richtig
wäre die ukraine mitglied der nato hätte
putin die ukraine eben nicht angegriffen
so aber jetzt ist das alles vergossene
milch was mir viel wichtiger wäre wäre
die frage was lernen wir eigentlich nach
vorne raus weil das was jetzt mit
russland passiert gebe ich ihnen brief
und siegel ist in den nächsten fünf bis
zehn jahren eine frage auch im
verhältnis zu china und da haben wir
doch genau die gleichen themen nord
stream 2 von russland ist die
seidenstraße der chinesen
einfluss überall auf der welt und von
daher würde ich mir wünschen dass sich
die deutsche politik in ihrer und auch
die wirtschaft im übrigen in ihrem
verhältnis zu china jetzt mal legt was
können wir denn da so machen dass wir
nicht in zehn jahren in der situation
sind wir alle wieder sagen ach butt
hätte man nicht vor zehn jahren andere
im caravan friedrich merz damit ich höre
ihn nicht ich sehe nicht mit genau
dieser aussage ständiger friedrich merz
schon seit vier jahren seit er
öffentlich wieder auftritt sie können
sich seine reden anschauen war einer der
ersten deutschen politiker die das thema
china überhaupt wieder angesprochen
haben und immer wieder darauf
hingewiesen hat wie sich dieser staat
entwickelt er natürlich auch aus seiner
wirtschaftlichen expertise aus sich auch
ganz genau anschaut was sie denn sagt
sie ist wie putin der sagt auch genau
das was er machen will und diese und die
chinesen sagen dass im grunde genommen
die letzten 200 jahren fehler der
geschichte waren weil man keine
weltmacht mir bleiben noch ein jahr bei
der these von new yorks dass merkel
putin mehr genutzt hat als schröder und
es wurde auch gerade gesagt dass merkel
jetzt abgetaucht ist oder gerade
trotzdem mitarbeiter wähler als
kommunikationsprofi ist merkel
abgetaucht was können wir denn als
abschlussfrage zu dieser these von der
kanzlerin erwarten das müssen wir da
fragen im büro die gemeinde kann sich ja
mal nachfragen oder hat tut
wahrscheinlich einmal wie schon gesagt
wir haben außer zwei glaube ich sehr
dürren statements bisher nichts gehört
zur eingangs diese von uli vielleicht
auch nur ganz kurz und muss ich nur
vergegenwärtigen 2008 war die
schwarzmeerflotte der russen noch auf
der krim damals stationiert und man muss
sich die frage stellen ob dieser
konflikt wirklich vermieden hätte werden
können oder vielleicht früher
ausgebrochen wäre sogar wenn man in den
russen mit einem mit einer
nato-mitgliedschaft ein nato staaten ja
als euro machen die anderen araber sind
nicht also wie gesagt hinterher sind
einfach schlauer ich glaube nicht dass
das funktioniert hätte aber da ich
glaube mein letzter satz meinerseits man
kann daraus lernen dass
unklare verhältnisse für einen staat
also wenn man ihnen eine grauzone stößt
das war die ukraine wo man nicht wusste
wozu gehört überhaupt gehört die zu
europa zum besten oder ist sie nach wie
vor auf moskau orientiert die ost
ukraine war richtung moskau in die
andere hälfte war richtung europa
orientiert und sie gehörte weder zur eu
und zur nato und das ist 2008 an gericht
politikfeld zeit dahin macht er so
schrecklich weil in einem solchen
machtvakuum kann man eingreifen und zwar
auch militärisch und das ist passiert
und ich will ja nicht der angela merkel
entgegen halten ja ich habe auch nicht
gedacht dass putin den fehler macht
finde ich einen solchen krieg
anzuzetteln aber soll sie doch mal uns
mal erklären wie sie damals die
situation eingeschätzt hat warum sie so
entschieden hat gegen george bush